now to the pandemic the omicron variant
of the coronavirus is not going away the
ba5 subvariant now circulating in the
u.s may be the most contagious yet it
accounts for more than half of the cases
with infections surging across all age
groups dr celine gounder is editor at
large for kff's kaiser health news and
an infectious disease specialist good
morning to you
what do we know as far as the severity
of illness the seriousness of the ba-5
that seems to be more contagious there
are early hints that the ba-5
sub-variant of omicron may be more
virulent so in other words may cause
more severe disease it's a little early
to say this is based on animal data but
at the same time if this is spreading
widely if we're seeing a lot of people
infected even a small percentage of many
people means a lot of people in the
hospital
that's what i was gonna ask
hospitalizations deaths is there more
concern now that we'll see some of those
numbers go up as well we are seeing
hospitalizations go up um the good news
is most of those people are not ending
up in the icu the percentage ending up
in the icu is a lot lower than in
previous waves but i think it's really
important to hammer home vaccines work
so the parts of the country the counties
where you have the biggest increase in
hospitalizations these are counties that
have lower vaccination rates somewhere
between the 30s and 60 percent fully
vaccinated about three hundred thousand
children under the age of five have
received a vaccine dose for coven 19.
another 18 million have not are you
concerned about that pace
my colleagues at the kaiser family
foundation have done polling on this
about one in five parents of kids under
five plan to get their kid vaccinated
right away that includes my
three-year-old niece who has an
appointment next week okay we're very
excited about that um but then you have
another 40 or so who want to wait and
see it i think the question is going to
be
how long how long do they want to wait
and see and then you have another 40 who
are like no way not unless there's a
requirement so i do think there's work
to be done to encourage parents and
pediatricians are going to be really
central to that on the timing question
and forgive me if you mentioned this but
if for grown-ups who are thinking about
an omicron booster that might be
available in the fall should they get a
booster now that's not omicron specific
or should they wait
tony i've been getting this question a
lot over and over again i think people
are really confused do not try to game
this out if you are eligible for a
vaccine so if you are over 50 50 and up
and anybody who has an
immuno-compromising condition is
eligible for that second booster so that
fourth dose of vaccine don't wait
getting a booster now will not prevent
you from getting the updated vaccine in
the fall that doesn't say so then there
might be another i wouldn't say a fifth
but it depends how many shots you have
you may be looking for one more because
as you said this still is the vaccines
are working the way that they are
supposed to they are working the way
they're supposed to but the
virus continues to mutate ba-5 you can
think of it as omicron number five is
really different from the original
omicron the og there's a big difference
between the two and so even if you had
your vaccinations even if you had an
infection with omicron your protection
against ba five omicron number five is
just not as good looking down the line
is is this going to become the norm i
have friends and family that are asking
me they are just going to be taking this
many shots every single year yeah what
do you think when do you like i have a
family member who wants to go to a
funeral it's actually my mom actually
guys covered positive she her brother
died now she can't go and participate
fully in the funeral on on saturday
because when are we gonna get to a point
where people are like you know what it's
like the flu you can still do big
important things in your life that are
really that matter right i think the
this is going to take a couple years um
you're probably looking at at least
another year or two of you know more
variants emerging trying to match the
vaccine to the variant more boosters
especially for older people
immunocompromised people
eventually this will plateau and settle
out but we're not right there yet oh wow
it feels like we've been saying a couple
years for a couple years but dr gander
thank you we appreciate it it's not on
you're right